Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain the Japanese film
called “The Taste Of Tea.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie revolves around the Haruno family
who lives in a small village in Japan.
At the beginning of the movie, the grandfather
plays with the youngest daughter Sachiko Haruno.
As the little girl sits alone behind her,
we see her doppelganger double the size of
her.
Sachiko has been troubled by this massive
form of herself following her around.
She thinks of ways to get rid of it often
but has never actually tried anything.
One day at school, she is in the morning assembly
yawning because she is bored.
At the same time, she sees her larger self
sitting on the bars and yawning as well.
In the classroom, Sachiko dives into her thoughts
and thinks of ways to get rid of the giant.
She remembers a story her uncle Ayano had
told her and her brother a few years back.
When Ayano was just a boy, there used to be
a large forest called the haunted forest.
People used to say that the forest was cursed
and anyone who went there attracted spirits.
One day, Ayano was roaming around the jungle,
collecting birds’ eggs.
But he had forgotten to go to the toilet before
leaving, so he was struggling to hold it in.
He tells himself that he can make it home
in time but changes his mind when he sees
a large egg on the ground.
He decides to defecate on the egg.
After that, as he pulls his pants up, he notices
that the egg is half underground.
He starts thinking about why someone buried
such a massive egg instead of bringing it
home with them.
Then, he sees the feces on top of the egg
and thinks that defecating on it might be
weirder than burying it.
Thinking about a lot of things, he leaves
the jungle for the day.
Since the thought of the egg never leaves
his mind, Ayano goes back the other day to
look for it.
But since he is not familiar with the jungle,
he never finds the egg again.
However, Ayano doesn’t give up and looks
for the egg every day.
Until one day, a man with several tattoos
and blood dripping from his body appears in
front of him.
Ayano looks at him in fear, but the man doesn’t
say anything.
From that day onwards, he sees the man everywhere.
At first, Ayano is terrified and bothered
by the stranger following him, but with time,
he gets used to being followed.
He also mentions that the stranger had his
feces on his head.
One day, when Ayano was able to do a flip
on the playground bar, the man disappeared
and never came back again.
Sachiko also contemplates learning to do a
backflip to get rid of the giant.
But what she doesn’t know is that the day
the man stopped following Ayano, the police
had found a skull buried in the forest with
feces on top of it.
So, it turns out the egg Ayano defecated on
was actually a human skull.
In the following scene, we see Sachiko’s
elder brother Hajime in his school.
He has a love letter in his hands, addressed
to him by some girl.
She calls him to meet in a restaurant after
school.
Later, we see four of Hajime’s in the said
restaurant talking about girls.
One of them is dressed as a girl as well.
As they talk, we find out that the love letter
was actually left by them so they can prank
Hajime.
Just then, Hajime cycles towards the restaurant,
and the boys get ready to prank him.
However, to their disappointment, he cycles
to his home without stopping by the restaurant.
A voice narrates to us that Hajime has lost
his faith in relationships after he heard
a couple fighting about cosmetic surgeries
in a restaurant and after he saw a guy who
was beaten by his girlfriend.
Next, we see Hajime and Sachiko’s mother
Yoshiko at her job.
She works as a designer in animated film projects.
Her boss is a pervert who wants to get together
with Yoshiko.
That day he scolds a worker for bringing her
pet to work.
Later at night, everyone is at home when the
father, Nobuo, plays a board game called Go
with Hajime.
The boy has been playing the game for a long
time and is getting quite good at it.
The next day at school, a student named Suzuishi
is transferred to Hajime’s class.
He instantly develops feelings for the girl
but is too shy to even talk to her.
After school, we see grandfather Akira, Ayano,
Sachiko, and mother Yoshiko drinking tea together.
They stay in silence for a very long time,
enjoying the beverage.
Sometime later, Sachiko runs to the living
room and stares into nothingness.
Her giant doppelganger is also beside her,
sitting in silence.
Fed up with the giant, she finally decides
to learn to do a backflip on a bar and get
rid of it.
She runs to a restricted area nearby, where
lies a deserted playground.
However, she looks at the playing bar for
a long time and returns back home without
trying to play on it.
The following day at school, a girl asks the
new transfer student, Suzuishi, what club
she will choose for after-school practice.
Suzuishi says that she wants to join the board
game “Go” club.
Hajime hears this and is over the moon, knowing
that he and Suzuishi share an interest.
On his way back home, he cycles while fantasizing
about Suzuishi.
Later, when he is alone in his room, Hajime
fantasizes an elaborate fake scenario and
fights imaginary men to save his “girl.”
In the following scene, he is back in school
that evening.
Suzuishi is with her friend talking as he
spies on her from afar.
After a while, he meets his father while returning
home on a metro.
They both witness two men in some kind of
costumes making noise and clicking pictures.
When they get off the metro, the men get in
a fight with some strangers, and the father
and the son run away from the scene.
Now, the family is at the dinner table as
the two tell them what they saw in the metro.
Ayano almost doesn’t believe them because
of the absurdity of the incident.
The next day, the mother of the family Yoshiko
is at work.
Before leaving, she asks her boss not to call
her the following day because she is on a
leave.
It is evident that he has been bothering her
to go out with him.
He promises to leave her alone but as soon
as she leaves, he calls her husband and tells
him Yoshiko is cheating on him.
Yoshiko, who is just outside the door, hears
this and attacks her boss for spreading rumors
about her.
Cut to the next scene, Sachiko wakes up to
a nightmare of her and her doppelganger swimming
together.
She runs to the abandoned playground again
and gets on the play bar for the first time.
At the same time, Ayano goes to a shop owned
by his ex-girlfriend, who is now married to
another man.
He talks to her awkwardly at first but then
opens up and says he is glad she is happy
in her life.
The girl says the same, and the two separate
after getting a closure of their relationship.
After that, he lays by the side of a river
to relax.
He notices a man his age dancing nearby and
befriends him.
The next day, Yoshiko gets a call from her
boss, who wants uncle Ayano’s help.
Since Ayano is a manga artist and a record
producer, he wants him to record a song.
He even invites grandfather Akira to be in
his music video.
At first, Ayano declines to record his song,
but he eventually agrees after the family
asks him to.
The grandfather is very happy to be a part
of the song and begins singing day and night.
Later that day, Sachiko is in her classroom,
and her giant companion is watching her while
lying on the school’s playground.
After school, she goes to the playground again
to practice backflipping.
This time, her grandfather watches her from
afar and is relieved that she isn’t doing
something harmful.
He leaves soon after.
At night, Ayano brings his new friend over
for dinner.
After dinner, the family sits together as
the father Nobuo, who happens to be a hypnotherapist,
performs a procedure on everyone to make them
relax.
He tries to hypnotize everyone, but it only
works on Yoshiko, Ayano, and his new friend.
The three fall unconscious while sitting up.
After a while, they regain their consciousness
and say that they feel rejuvenated.
The mother, Yoshiko, explains to her daughter
how it feels to be hypnotized since she didn’t
get to enjoy the experience.
She describes it as being able to move freely
into space.
The next day, Hajime goes to the library to
return some books on the board game “Go.”
The members of the “Go” club notice his
interest and invite him to join the club since
they are low on members.
Hajime shyly accepts the offer and goes to
the club with them.
Suzuishi is there too.
He plays a game against a boy and easily wins
it as Suzuishi watches.
However, she leaves right after without talking
to him.
At the same time, Sachiko is at the playground
practicing doing a backflip when a man’s
head emerges from the ground.
Sachiko runs away in fear and is caught by
two men.
She tells them about the “mud man.”
The three return back to the playground and
rescue the man who claims he had been stuck
underground for three days.
At night, she tells the story to her mother
and two of her co-workers who have come over
for dinner.
Some days later, Ayano records a song for
Akira and Yoshiko’s boss.
After listening to the awful song, Ayano and
his co-workers are shown flying to the sky.
One day at school, Suzuishi is playing a game
of Go with a friend but he leaves midway.
As she packs up, Hajime enters the room.
He sees she is alone and is about to leave
but Suzuishi challenges him to a game of Go.
The two begin to play in silence.
All of a sudden, Hajime tells Suzuishi that
it was his dream to play a match of Go with
her.
Suzuishi then tells him that they should play
every day.
After the game, they leave the school together
under the same umbrella.
Hajime is over the moon to finally be able
to talk to his crush.
The next day at work, Yoshiko presents her
animation to her coworkers.
It is inspired by the feelings she goes through
when she is hypnotized.
Everyone loves the animation and claps for
Yoshiko in appreciation.
Back at home, Sachiko peeps into her grandfather’s
room to see him lying limp on the floor.
In the following scene, we see the whole family
in a metro, returning home after the grandfather’s
funeral.
Later, the four of them sit at the front porch
and drink tea in silence, remembering the
grandfather.
Then, they go into his study room and look
through his belongings.
To their surprise, they find sketchbooks with
paintings of the whole family.
In the paintings, Yoshiko is seen walking
with an umbrella, Nobuo is running, Hajime
is on his bicycle while Sachiko is doing a
backflip on a playing bar.
In the following scene, we see Hajime with
Suzuishi playing Go while talking to her confidently.
Yoshiko is working on her animations while
Sachiko is in the playground attempting to
do a backflip.
She finally manages to do one and freezes
in shock.
Just then, her giant self emerges from the
ground and flies away to the sky.
A giant sunflower also emerges from the same
place and engulfs Sachiko.
It grows bigger and bigger, ultimately taking
over the whole world and turning into dust.
At last, Sachiko levitates back to the playground.
The movie ends as we are shown all the characters
of the movie watching the beautiful sunset.
Unlike the typical type of dysfunctional families
that are shown in most movies, the taste of
tea doesn’t have any dramatic encounters.
In fact, it is made in such a way that the
viewers would find the encounters between
the characters relatable to their life.
Modern films have been pushing dystopia and
pessimism to the viewers while this movie
shows that not everything about reality is
always negative.
The movie looks uncomplicated and straightforward
in the first look but has several metaphors
and hidden messages throughout it.
Some viewers believe that Sachiko seeing her
giant self following her is her creating fantasies
because she is frustrated by the time it takes
for her to grow up.
So, she keeps herself entertained by trying
to get rid of the giant.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank you for watching.